Das war's für heute.
Weiter geht's!
Moin!
Seh schon, die ersten sind am Start!
Und das nur 40 Sekunden nachdem der Stream
on gegangen ist. Massive!
High Speed! Speedrun!
Schon mal den Biodöner in Frankfurt probiert.
Ich weiß gar nicht mal, wo es Biodöner gibt.
die preisfrage ist auch viel eher was kostet der bio döner wenn er als ich habe letzter
zeit wenig döner gefuttert aber wenn der bio döner in diese doppelte kostet
von einem nicht bio döner dann weiß ich nicht wie sehr ich gewillt bin 14 euro
für den döner ich weiß ja nicht 14 euro ist schon ordentlich
Man ist ja nicht so, als könnten wir es uns nicht leisten.
Die meisten hier arbeiten ja in der IT und verdienen auch ganz gut.
Aber ich sehe es...
Ich sehe es sicher ein.
Ich bin eh voll geizig geworden, was das angeht.
Also...
Weiß ich.
Ich gehe lieber in letzter Zeit nicht essen,
als zum Beispiel in irgendeinem random Restaurant, wo ich dann schon erwarte,
eigentlich enttäuscht zu werden, weil es entweder zu kleine Portionen hat,
zu teuer ist, nicht richtig schmeckt oder sonst was.
Ich bin da super kritisch geworden.
Es gibt ganz wenige Läden, wo ich hingehe, wo ich der Meinung bin,
dass das ein gutes Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis hat, schmeckt, große Portionen hat,
also ausreichende Portionen.
Ich war beispielsweise vorgestern oder so, weiß nicht mehr, wann genau,
war ich Sushi All You Can Eat futtern.
Das hat 36 Euro
gekostet, aber ich hab
denen da auch das Band leer gefressen.
Video,
wenn ich Battlefield 6 gespielt hab.
Also,
ich hab das mit
getränkt, ne natürlich nicht.
Ich hab noch ein kleines Wasser
genommen, was irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
schon 3,80 oder so gekostet hat.
Das ist teuer.
Also am Ende hab ich um die 40 Euro bezahlt.
Ende habe ich ziemlich genau 40 Euro bezahlt
Und ich hab halt
Ich hab den halt das Band leer gefressen
Und das musste auch sein
Weil wenn ich schon All You Can Eat mache
Und wenn das schon so teuer ist
Dann muss auch ordentlich
Pipo Fett gemacht werden
Ja
Ja deswegen hab ich ja auch die All You Can Eat
Geschichte genommen.
Und
zwar hier in Frankfurt.
Aber der Pepo
stört mich gerade ein bisschen.
Hier war das in Frankfurt.
Da haben wir bestimmt
noch Bilder.
Ja.
Aber
innen drinnen
gibt es hier
so Bänder, die durchlaufen.
Und je nachdem, welche Farbe
der Teller hat, kostet es eigentlich
unterschiedlich viel.
Aber,
nachdem ich ja die All-You-Can-Eat-Variante hatte,
habe ich überhaupt nicht nach Tellerfarben
geguckt. Gut,
die aufwendigeren Sachen
waren natürlich auch auf den teureren Tellern drauf.
Aber ich habe reingehauen.
Die mussten dreimal
abräumen bei mir und am Ende standen immer noch Teller.
Also ich habe an die 30
Teller oder so gefressen.
Das ist schon ordentlich.
Aber es ist nicht schlecht.
Also kann man nichts sagen.
Ich fand das nicht übel.
Da kannst du mich spotten mit 100 anderen Leuten auch noch.
Aber fand ich nicht schlecht.
Die waren früher...
Früher hatten die noch ein bisschen mehr Auswahl.
Und das war natürlich deutlich günstiger.
Aber mittlerweile...
Gerade Sushi ist halt auch super teuer.
Egal wo.
Also wenn es gescheit ist.
Kostet halt übelst Kohle.
War früher schon teuer.
Aber mittlerweile ist es halt richtig teuer.
Und wenn ich irgendwo hingehe mit All You Can Eat, dann mache ich es auch so, dass ich extra wenig esse morgens,
dass ich mittags mich so heftig vollfuttern kann, dass sich das auch lohnt.
Und wisst ihr, was auch ganz schlimm ist von der Fresserei?
Irgendwelche Teambuilding-Events oder sowas, wo es dann kostenlos Essen gibt.
Wenn das Essen kostenlos ist, muss ich, das ist, weiß nicht, so ungeschriebenes Gesetz für mich.
ich muss nach möglichkeit alles was es gibt oder egal ob ich satt bin oder nicht letztes
letztes team building event was ich gefressen habe alle alle paar minuten in den kuchen ins
da umsonst gab irgendwelche sandwiches irgendwelchen süßkram morgens zum frühstück
hier einmal quer durch vier verschiedene Teller und ich weiß noch zum Abendessen,
zum Abendessen, ich hatte schon gar keinen Hunger mehr richtig zum Abendessen.
So viel habe ich den Tag über gefuttert.
Und zum Abendessen habe ich dann gegessen einmal Handkäs mit Musik,
das ist sowas richtig urhessisches.
Das ist Käse mit Zwiebel und so.
Da kann man gut furzen danach.
Deswegen heißt das vielleicht auch so.
Weiß nicht.
So.
Und danach habe ich noch Fried Chicken gegessen.
Also das hieß dann irgendwie Wiener Backhähnchen oder sowas.
Aber das waren im Endeffekt Fried Chicken.
Und danach noch Eis.
Und ich habe mich so heftig voll gefressen.
Weil es hat halt nichts gekostet.
und wenn es nichts kostet, habe ich so das Gefühl,
ich muss jetzt richtig das ausnutzen,
dass es nichts kostet.
Muss reinhauen
bis zum Platzen.
Habe ich auch gemacht.
Handkäs in den Döner. Na, ich weiß ja nicht,
ob das so richtig passt.
Aber wenn es ihm schmeckt,
wieso?
Sobald es Buffet und All-You-Can-Eat
gibt, da muss reingehauen werden
ohne Ende.
Das bis
aus den Ohren wieder rauskommt
im Endeffekt.
Es muss alles rein.
Weil wenn man
schon All You Can Eat bezahlt,
das ist ja auch meistens ordentlich teuer,
dann muss sich das halt auch lohnen.
Stell euch mal vor,
ich gehe da hin,
kaufe mir Sushi All You Can Eat
und dann esse ich
so wenig, dass ich mit pro Teller
bezahlen günstiger wäre.
Das wäre doch bescheuert, wenn ich All You Can Eat mache.
Wenn schon das Doppelte futtern.
Dass sich das auch richtig lohnt.
Ach, guck mal.
Das Zeug läuft ja noch von gestern.
Omega-Keg.
Heute machen wir das mal in ordentlich.
weihnachtsfeier sind auch immer heftig wobei ich da sagen muss ich war jetzt glaube ich seit
15 jahren oder so ja war ich nicht mehr auf der weihnachtsfeier bin einfach nicht mehr
hingegangen das letzte mal auf der weihnachtsfeier war ich da war ich
noch beim provider nach 15 jahre stimmt nicht 15 jahre stimmt nicht 13 jahre oder so da war ich
noch beim provider da war ich das letzte mal auf der weihnachtsfeier und irgendwann habe ich mir
gedacht irgendwie hast du da überhaupt keinen bock drauf und da einfach nur hinzugehen weil sich
irgendwie gehört in anführungszeichen war mir dann auch zu blöd und jetzt stellt sich die frage ja
ähnlich mehr weil ich ja schon seit einigen jahren dezember immer komplett urlaub habe dann fällt das
mit der weihnachtsfeier flach gucken vielleicht gehe ich irgendwann mal wieder auf die weihnachts
weil weiß ich wie das bei euch ist habt ihr bock auf weihnachtsfeiern ich fand das fand das immer
so gezwungen alles also ich hab da keinen bock drauf gar nicht weil ich die leute nicht ab kann
oder so das ist überhaupt nicht das problem mit meist verstehe ich mich richtig gut überhaupt
keine schmerzen mit aber auf weihnachtsfeier habe ich trotzdem keinen bock weiß nicht wie
doch bei euch ist aber für mich ist für mich ist weihnachtsfeier nichts ich finde es hat auch keinen
sinn wenn man sich wenn man sich zu irgendwelchen events zwingen muss dass man sich quasi so
innerlich überwinden muss dahin zu gehen es meistens auch keinen sinn dass dann für alle
beteiligten doof man selbst hat keinen bock man sitzt dann darum die anderen
merken dass man keinen bock hat und macht doch eigentlich gar keinen sinn
wir machen mal kurz us updates und dann wahrscheinlich reboot
Also ich trinke auf der Weihnachtsfeier nix mehr.
Ähm.
Also.
Ich kann mich noch an eine der ersten Weihnachtsfeiern erinnern.
Da war ich noch Azubi.
Da haben sich die Leute so krass besoffen.
Die sind umgekippt.
Und da gab es Drama.
Leute.
Da gab es Drama.
Da kam dann sogar die Polizei irgendwann.
Und jetzt passt mal auf, was für ein Drama.
Es gab auf, also dort, wo ich die Ausbildung gemacht habe,
dort gab es eine Weihnachtsfeier.
Da haben sich alle super krass besoffen.
Und wie das so ist, wenn die Leute sich super krass besoffen haben,
dann fallen da so die Hemmungen mit der Zeit.
und
da ist dann eine
auf der Weihnachtsfeier
ist dann eine mit einem heimgegangen
kann man sich denken
was die gemacht haben
zumindest
wussten das ihre Eltern nicht
dass die
diesen Abend
nicht heimkommt
und als es dann irgendwann
keine Ahnung halb eins oder so war
Haben die sich Sorgen gemacht
Und haben dann irgendwann die Polizei gerufen
Wo die ist
Ja also Weihnachtsfeier
Keine Ahnung
Das ist
Cringe Time
Und?
Wo ist die Malware?
Nicht zu sehen.
Okay.
Ich mach mal Up...
Oh, Update.
Update ist durch.
Dann machen wir noch hier...
Oh, was ist das hier?
Leaked, Leute.
Leaked.
Ich weiß nicht für was, aber...
Massive, massive...
Huge Passwort Leaked.
Was wollte ich jetzt machen hier?
Okay, nochmal updaten.
Schon drin, okay.
Alles gut, Leute.
Schon eingehacksort.
Racial Studio Code Update gibt's.
Gestern in Frankfurt
mich mit einem Kollegen getroffen,
wie sie was gefuttert
und auf dem Heimweg
also das Racial Studio Code
braucht immer ein bisschen. Und auf dem
Heimweg gehe ich ja dann zum Hauptbahnhof
und fahre vom Hauptbahnhof heim.
Und da habe ich mal drauf
geachtet. Also ich glaube,
ich habe nicht ein Wort Deutsch
gehört auf dem Weg zum Hauptbahnhof.
Also bis in den Hauptbahnhof rein,
bis ans Gleis.
Ansonsten gefühlt alle Sprachen, die es
gibt, aber nicht ein Wort
Deutsch.
Da waren wieder
Gestalten am Start.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Wenn ihr am Platz der Republik seid, weiß ich, ob da manchmal Leute von euch durchlaufen, da so an der Ecke, Platz der Republik, lauft ihr öfters mal vorbei und da ist so ein Wiener Feinbäcker oder wie dieses Ding heißt.
Da müsst ihr mal gucken, da ist seit ein paar Wochen ist da eine Blutlache davor.
Mittlerweile ist nicht mal komplett klar zu sehen, aber ihr müsst mal drauf achten, wenn ihr vorbeitauft.
Das ist halt typisch Frankfurt Bahnhofsviertel.
Reboot.
Ja, ich weiß, die Uhrzeit zum Streamen ist nicht so gut, aber deswegen ist das ja auch der Stream für alle Homeoffice-Enjoyer.
Geht nicht anders.
Die Urlaub haben wir, die können ja auch von Home enjoyen.
Da beim Busbahnhof?
Nee.
Nee, nee, da laufe ich.
Also da bin ich früher öfters vorbeigelaufen,
weil ich ja zur Berufsschule fahren musste.
Aber da laufe ich halt so gut wie gar nicht mehr vorbei.
Muss er am nächsten Jahr mehrmals die Woche
mit der Bahn nach Frankfurt pendeln?
Also, jetzt lasst euch nicht so sehr davon beeinflussen,
was ich hier über Frankfurt erzähle.
Frankfurt an sich ist relativ sicher.
Also das ist nicht so, dass du da Angst haben musst,
erstochen zu werden direkt am Bahnhof.
Wobei man sagen muss, die letzten Jahre
sind ja da schon einige Dinger passiert.
Von
irgendwelchen Messerstechaktionen
zu Leute
vor's Gleis schmeißen, also
vor den Zug aufs Gleis schmeißen,
so rum. Also
ganz so ohne ist da nicht, aber
im Großen und Ganzen ist Frankfurt, sogar Frankfurt
Bahnhofstürtel halbwegs sicher. Da muss man sich
keine Gedanken machen.
Aber schön ist es da nicht.
Die Bahn würde mich tatsächlich
auch mehr abfacken als Frankfurt.
Bahn ist das Schlimmste.
Ich finde es mittlerweile heftig,
wenn man sich mal überlegt,
wie sehr das einfach
gesellschaftlich mittlerweile
hingenommen wird, dass die Bahn scheiße
ist. Also
jeder
macht Witze über die Bahn
und man lacht das dann immer so weg.
Man hat komplett schon,
das ist schon komplett in die Normalität
im Kopf übergegangen,
dass das einfach so ein grundlegendes
fast schon Naturgesetz ist.
Die Bahn ist scheiße.
Das ist einfach
so gegeben.
Das ist halt auch schon
heftig ja also das ist einfach das wird schon als gegeben hingenommen dass es
einfach abgrundtief scheiße ist die bahn
es wird auch immer schlimmer ja ja mittlerweile geben sich ja nicht mal mehr
mühe ihre eigenen statistiken ordentlich zu faken
Ich glaube nicht, dass das prinzipiell daran liegt, sondern wie das gemanagt wird oder
wie da die Prioritäten gesetzt werden und dass Autos in Deutschland einfach das wichtigste
Sinnwasser gibt.
Ist Web Application 11 der Vorgänger von Web Application 12, ne von Web Application
69. Ne, Moment, Moment.
Wir müssen jetzt, wir müssen jetzt
Gen, ähm,
was ist das? Alpha? Ne.
Gen Beta
Meme
von Web Application
6.7.
Das ist so ein Ding, das verstehe ich nicht.
Was da dran lustig sein soll.
Ich mein, 69 ist schon nicht wirklich
lustig.
Aber 6ix7ine ist...
Ich bin
vielleicht einfach zu alt. Ich check's nicht.
Also,
ich hab mir das zwar durchgelesen, wo
das herkommt. Letztendlich
ja von irgendwelchen TikTok-Baseball-
Memes oder Basketball-
Memes oder sowas. Aber...
Also, keine Ahnung.
Man hört das nur manchmal, wenn man an der Bushaltestelle
vorbeiläuft oder irgendwelche...
Es sind ja keine Zoomers
Gen-Alpha-Leute, keine Ahnung, was immer,
ähm, rumstehen
und dann irgendwie was erzählen von
Digga, Handy-Akku
6-7 und sowas.
So.
Wo war mein Stängel hier?
Ich muss erst mal das Zeug wieder starten.
Starte das verdammte Spiel.
Ah.
Moment, Moment, ich habe ja immer noch diesen dummen Bug.
Seems like you don't have
Chatbrains Gateway installed. Ich weiß jetzt übrigens
auch, woran das liegt.
Also vermute ich. Wir können mal gucken, ob es wirklich
daran liegt. Meine Vermutung
ist,
die Fehlermeldung ist einfach Schrott.
Und es liegt
daran, dass ich hier
Firefox Developer Edition
als Browser gesetzt habe und
gar nicht installiert habe hier.
Ich glaube, das ist das Problem.
Das können wir jetzt gleich mal ausprobieren.
Gucken wir mal, ob das vielleicht das war.
Siehste?
Das war's.
Die Fehlermeldung ist einfach nur dumm.
die schenken geblieben da mal warten bis die idee auf ist
Genau.
Fehler weg, Informatik.
Informatikord.
Fuck.
Muss man noch irgendwas updaten?
Habe ich noch irgendwas vergessen?
Ich glaube, das war's.
Können wir gleich loslegen.
Immer was trinken.
Merk schon.
Letzten Tage wieder öfters gestreamt.
Mein Hals fühlt sich schon richtig, richtig
trocken an. Das liegt immer daran,
wenn ich eine Weile nicht so regelmäßig
gestreamt habe, dann bin ich
das nicht gewöhnt,
drei Stunden am Stück ohne Pause,
ohne Punkt und Komma zu labern.
Deswegen muss ich jetzt hier ein bisschen
Kamillentee trinken.
Kamillentee ist generell gut.
Gut gegen Erkältung, gut um den Magen zu beruhigen.
so muss man gucken wir haben uns noch irgendwo aufgeschrieben
metriken da haben wir stehen geblieben bei web sockets bei web sockets immer stehen geblieben
betrieben und sonst ich habe mir gedacht wir versuchen heute mal das letzte mal letzten
streams ging es ja hauptsächlich darum sich ein bisschen feeling für quarkus zu kriegen ich habe
mir gedacht heute machen wir mal ordentliches java ich weiß gar nicht ob ich da in der lage
bin ordentliches java zu machen heute machen wir nämlich noch wie funktionieren http clients
haben wir so überlegt http clients wir machen mit metriken weiter mit ritzeln so jetzt entweder auf
deutsch oder auf englisch oder überhaupt richtigen richtigen worte und und wir machen das besonders
ordentlich. Mal schauen. Bei Metriken bauen wir noch heute File Size Metrik ein und noch die
Prozessmetriken haben wir immer noch nicht. Wir machen es einfach mal ein bisschen ordentlich.
Das interessiert mich auch, wie man HTTP Clients in Quarkus verwendet. Agile muss auch sein. Oh,
Oh, du hast recht.
Leute, Sprintplanning.
Auf geht's.
Wobei, nee.
Sprintplanning haben wir ja schon gemacht.
Auf Daily Scrum.
Stand-up.
Habt ihr irgendwelche Blocker?
Chat, habt ihr irgendwelche Blocker?
Bin ich froh, dass ich keine Stand-ups gerade machen muss.
Leute, Teams Call startet.
Spülmaschine muss aus...
Ist das der Blocker?
Welche T-Shirt-Größe ist das denn?
Und kannst du da nicht irgendwelche Synergie-Effekte nutzen?
Gibt es auch bestimmt Low-Hanging-Fruits, die du da ernten kannst.
Das ist der Key zum Success, würde ich sagen.
Was sagst du eigentlich zu der GitHub-Billing-Thematik?
Ich habe es nur am Rande mitgekriegt.
Du meinst diese Geschichte, dass self-hosted GitHub Actions Runner
jetzt mit 0,02 Cent die...
Weiß ich nicht, Minute? Keine Ahnung, in welcher Zeit.
Das war bezahlt.
Ich habe gelesen, die haben angeblich wieder einen Rückzug gemacht.
Also ich finde es bescheuert.
Für einen self-hosted Runner zu bezahlen.
WTF?
Ich hoste was selbst und dann soll ich es noch bezahlen?
Das ist total hängen geblieben.
Bitte so schnell wie möglich ins Operative Doing kommen.
Ja, wir übergeben das dann in den Linienbetrieb, würde ich sagen, oder?
Was sagst du dazu, Crooked Monkey?
Teambuilding, wichtig.
Bitte auch mit
richtig vielen blöden Spielen dabei.
Wir haben,
wobei ich sagen würde, unser letztes Teambuilding,
die Spiele waren gar nicht so blöd.
Die gingen eigentlich voll klar.
Wir haben
im letzten Teambuilding
ein Spiel gemacht,
das, wie hieß denn das?
der vergiftete See oder irgendwie sowas.
Zumindest gab es eine Kiste mit Kletter-Equipment.
Und das ist so ein typisches Teambuilding-Game.
Es gab eine Kiste mit Kletter-Equipment,
also mit Seilen und irgendwelchen Haken und so drin.
Und dann hat der Trainer quasi so einen Bereich abgesteckt
und in der Mitte wurde da halt ein Zettel hingelegt
mit irgendwas, was da drauf gelegen hat.
Und man konnte da nicht hinlaufen.
Also das Ziel war es, den, weiß ich nicht,
was da drauf gelegen hat, Schlüssel oder so,
zu holen von dem
Platz, quasi von der Insel
im vergifteten oder verseuchten
See oder so, abgesteckter Bereich.
Das heißt, du musstest mit den Klettersachen
irgendwas bauen,
wo du einen da hin
ziehen kannst.
Der Boden ist Lava, genau sowas
in der Richtung.
Das war eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht. Und was wir auch gemacht haben, das war tatsächlich aber ziemlich cringe, wir haben Zelte aufgebaut, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass die Hälfte der Leute nichts gesehen hat.
Also man musste sich so eine Augenbinde überziehen und die Leute, die gesehen haben, mussten den Leuten, die nichts gesehen haben, erklären, wie sie das Zelt aufbauen müssen. Das war ein bisschen zum Fremdschämen.
Da wurden wir natürlich auch schön dabei fotografiert, dass es dann irgendein Bilderalbum gibt vom letzten Teambuilding Event.
Aber ich muss sagen, so schlimm sind die Teambuilding Events gar nicht.
Also die fand ich in der vorletzten Firma viel schlimmer.
Da waren die so super gezwungen und eklig.
Jetzt geht das klar.
Bei uns darf man jetzt ja sogar sagen,
was man machen will und was man auf gar keinen Fall machen will
zum Teambuilding und sowas.
Und da wird es dann auch dran gehalten.
Also das geht klar.
Aber das mit den Zelten war ein bisschen zum Fremdschämen.
Lieber Weihnachtsfeier.
Ganz ehrlich,
ich sehe es anders.
Also richtig Bock habe ich auf beides nicht.
Aber ich gehe tatsächlich lieber aufs Teambuilding-Event
als auf die Weihnachtsfeier.
Ja, früher oder später kommst du nicht dran vorbei.
Da stehen die ja drauf.
Ab und zu muss irgendein Teambuilding-Event gemacht werden.
als wäre nicht klar gewesen, dass Microsoft
GitHub zerstört. Also alles ist
jetzt ja an GitHub auch nicht schlecht geworden.
Insgesamt hat GitHub
weniger Ausfälle, habe ich den Eindruck,
zumindest mein persönlicher Eindruck, als vor Microsoft.
Ja, also
ich bin immer noch der Meinung, das war übertrieben,
dass viele Projekte kaum
Microsoft GitHub übernommen,
da geflüchtet sind von.
Jetzt sind sie auf irgendwelchen komischen Plattformen,
wo keiner sich dafür interessiert.
also ob es das so viel gebracht hat, weiß ich nicht.
Also aus meiner Sicht ist GitHub immer noch die beste Plattform für
Git-Hosting und wenn du willst, dass dein Projekt auch gefunden wird.
Wenn du einfach nur was brauchst, wo du dein Projekt hosten kannst,
wo es dich interessiert drumherum,
dann kannst du auf alle möglichen anderen Plattformen auch.
Gibt es Bitbucket eigentlich noch?
Ja, gibt es bestimmt noch.
Bitbucket.
Aber war das nicht so, dass Microsoft jetzt einen Rückzieher gemacht hat?
Mit dieser GitHub-Action-Thematik?
Ich habe heute Morgen irgendwas gelesen, dass Microsoft das wohl jetzt doch nicht machen will.
Wobei ich dann in diesen Artikel nicht reingeklickt habe.
Vielleicht war das auch bloß Clickbait oder Gbait.
Und das ist überhaupt nicht so.
So.
Java.
Kotlin.
Kotlin müssen wir übrigens auch demnächst machen.
Ich habe mir überlegt, wir machen das so.
Wenn wir das Ding hier fertig gebaut haben, das ist ja im Prinzip nur eine Beispielanwendung, wo ich sinnloses Zeug einbaue, damit ich ein bisschen Gefühl dafür kriege, wie Quarkus funktioniert.
Wenn wir das fertig haben in Java, dann bauen wir das um oder bauen das Ganze nochmal in Kotlin.
Und dann können wir mal vergleichen, was wirklich besser ist.
Ich muss aber sagen, nachdem ich ja früher Java immer geflamed habe, so immer, sag mal, so mit, so halb ernst gemeint, ja.
Jetzt, nachdem ich das benutzt habe, ich finde das gar nicht schlecht.
Ja, genau, Kotlin, die gleiche Anwendung mit Kotlin nochmal.
Ich finde das gar nicht schlecht
Also ich kann ja zu Java an sich
Von früher nichts sagen
Wie vergleicht man etwas
Wenn am Ende das gleiche rauskommt
Du baust das gleiche einmal in Java und dann in Kotlin
Dann hast du doch einen super Vergleich
Wie sich welche Sprache anfühlt
Du baust quasi genau das gleiche zweimal
Also ich kann jetzt dazu Java früher nichts sagen
Und letztens im Stream meinte auch einer
Java war früher richtig, richtig nervig
Die haben sich wohl einiges auch von C-Sharp abgeguckt
Den Eindruck hatte ich tatsächlich auch
Als ich Record Classes gesehen habe
Oder diese Stream-AP
Die doch schon ziemlich an Link erinnert
Aber finde ich gut
über wenn man sich essen gewählt gibt es glaube ich in java noch nicht aber wenn man sich die
guten sachen abguckt ist doch überhaupt kein problem genau switch expressions gibt es auch
ist doch überhaupt kein problem also mir ist es lieber die gucken sich die guten sachen ab
die funktionieren anstatt wie c++ laufen in den bulls einzubauen der überhaupt nicht durchdacht
es. Also dann lieber
so.
RC Sharp
ist auch meine Lieblingssprache.
Zusammen mit Ruby.
Aber Ruby
kann man leider nichts mal wirklich mit
anfangen. Ich finde,
Ruby ist eine super Programmiersprache, aber
leider
dadurch, dass
Rails so abgestiegen ist,
das ist ja kein Mensch oder kaum
einer, das kann man ja nicht sagen, keiner
kann man nicht sagen, aber kaum einer
macht noch irgendwas in Rails.
Wobei ja Ruby nicht zwangsläufig
nur für Rails Anwendung ist.
Damit auch jede Menge andere Sachen machen,
aber Großteil
des Hypes damals um Ruby
gab es halt wegen Rails.
Rails ist halt total auf dem
Absteigen, erst schon seit Jahren.
Keiner macht mehr neue Projekte in Rails.
So.
Dann wollen wir mal.
Ja.
Node.js ist eine JavaScript Runtime oder wie auch immer man das nennen soll.
letztendlich ist es ja chrome v8 gebundelt als extra tool ich würde eher
sagen nots ist als javascript runtime sowie dort net im endeffekt auch die
runtime ist und sie schafft die programmier sprache so wie ich sage es
nots die runtime und javascript halte die programmier sprache oder types
wobei es ja TypeScript an sich gar nicht gibt
wenn es um Node.js gibt
das wird ja transpiled nach JavaScript
ich glaube
äh
Deno und Ban
ich glaube die haben Native TypeScript
Unterstützung
wie es unter der Haube läuft
weiß ich nicht, ob die nicht auch einfach
nach JavaScript transpilen, nur dass du nicht extra noch
TypeScript installieren musst
weiß nicht wie das funktioniert wahrscheinlich so also wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben gehen
wir mal hier rein starten mark kurz unseren server gucken mal wo wir stehen geblieben
sind geht unsere webseite noch nicht mehr weiß warum nicht brauchen oder doch
brauchen unser websocket zeug geht nicht mehr guck mal kaputt gemacht das letzte
mal websocket ist problem da kann man gleich kommen gleich gucken was los ist
Also, wenn ihr den letzten Stream nicht dabei wart, wir haben gar nichts Großartiges gemacht, wir haben nur versucht so ein bisschen Gefühl für Quarkus zu kriegen.
Letztendlich haben wir eine Mini, wirklich Mini-Webanwendung gebaut, die eine statische HTML-Seite ausliefert, hier, statische Index-HTML ausliefert.
und dann gibt es einen Websocket Endpunkt
unter
slash ws
der
einmal in der Sekunde
hier über dieses interne Quarkus
Events System, kriegt er einmal in der
Sekunde eine Nachricht geschickt
und die schickt er halt
einfach ans Frontend weiter, fertig
mehr haben wir nicht gemacht
so
und jetzt das letzte Mal sind wir stehen geblieben
bei
Metriken einbauen
und dann wollte ich jetzt noch gucken, wie man
HTTP-Clients verwendet und ein bisschen mehr Sachen über WebSocket
schicken und
mal gucken, dass wir
mal versuchen, ordentliches Java
zu fabrizieren.
Erstmal User-Stories.
Was ist das denn?
Was ist Moskau?
Das kenne ich nicht.
User-Stories, ja, aber Moskau
ist mir neu.
Das ist bestimmt eine Abkürzung für irgendwas.
User-Story, das ist sowas richtig...
Also ganz...
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Must, should, could...
Wer denkt sich diesen ganzen Krempel eigentlich aus?
Da muss es doch irgendwie so eine...
So eine Brainstorming-Veranstaltung
aller Unternehmensberater geben,
alle 1-2 Jahre, wo sich
so Zeug ausgedacht wird, oder?
Anders kann ich mir nicht erklären, dass es das gibt.
Ich finde auch, die meisten
User-Stories sind immer so super
gezwungen.
So, falls sich irgendjemand benutzt,
ein Tool und sagt, boah, wäre es nicht
gut, wenn wir einen Date-Picker
hätten, anstatt dass
ich das Datum da von Hand reinschreiben
muss. So, da kann man nicht einfach
einen Feature-Request oder sowas machen und zu sagen
so, hey Leute, es wäre super praktisch, einen Date-Picker
zu haben, anstatt das
von Hand einzutragen. Nein, dann musst du eine
User-Story schreiben oder so.
Ich als User möchte eine einfache
Auswahl haben für
zum Datum auswählen.
Warum
so kompliziert?
Ah, vielleicht bin ich
einfach nur
zu Boomer, um User
stories zu verstehen
ja natürlich aber das ist bei mir nicht so einfach ich habe noch einen singleton
observer registriert wo man diese sachen subscriben kann während es generiert
geht ja auch so.
So, also.
Dann gucken wir mal. Wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Warum wird denn keine Websocket-Nachricht mehr geschickt?
Warte mal kurz schauen.
Websocket-Nachricht. Ach so.
Okay. Es wird keine Websocket-Nachricht
mehr geschickt, weil wir das letzte Mal
die Websocket-Geschichte kaputt gemacht haben.
Dann
machen wir doch erstmal diese
Metrik-Geschichte fertig. Also, als
Metriken will ich
zurückliefern.
Gucken wir mal hier mal in Curl.
Ah, guck mal, guck mal, aber die Metriken checkt er je nachdem.
Guck mal, wenn ich hier die Bash zumache, verschwindet die Metrik wieder.
Wenn ich die Bash aufmache, kriege ich wieder eine Bash-Metrik.
Prozess uptime.
Wir haben jetzt einfach mal nach allen Bash-Prozessen gescannt.
Wie gesagt, es soll ja nichts Sinnvolles am Ende bei rauskommen,
sondern wir sollen ein Gefühl dafür kriegen, wie man Sachen in Quarkus macht.
Und wenn ich noch eine Bash starte, kriegen wir noch eine dritte Metrik.
Jawohl, Funst, it's.
f-programmer wollen
so
die die die die die die die
ok gehen wir mal in uns also
wir abdecken muss gerade mal mich selbst da wieder rein finden
genau wir haben eine metrik für prozesse abteilen der metrik von major major page falls
was genau macht die anwendung es ist es ist ein sammelsurium aus sinnlosen sachen um ein
bisschen gefühl für quarkus zu kriegen das liefert einmal eine statische html seite aus
auf der nichts drauf zu sehen ist außer so ein icon und per websocket wird da einmal in
der sekunde was hingepusht das haben übrigens letztes mal kaputt gemacht deswegen siehst
jetzt hier nicht stehen das kann übrigens bei der gelegenheit gerade mal reparieren
Aber das mal hier rein das ist nicht schön aber ich will jetzt dass das websocket zeug mal wieder funzt
Okay jetzt sollte jetzt sollten die websockets geschichten ja okay was
Jetzt gehe ich
mehrere sachen geschickt also zumindest wir haben eine statische webseite
die ausgeliefert wird und über Websocket wird einmal in der Sekunde ein paar neue
Werte hierhin geschickt. Das ist im Prinzip mehr oder weniger alles. Dann haben wir geguckt,
wie man Background-Tasks macht in Quarkus und wie man Application-Config macht in Quarkus.
da muss ich sagen das ist glaube ich mit die schönste und griffigste art application config
zu machen die ich bisher gesehen habe also finde ich finde ich sogar noch ein ticken besser wobei
es sehr ähnlich ist als in spring boot finde ich besser als in asp.net core gut in go gibt es direkt
sowas in der Form eingebaut
nicht. Da muss man sich das selbst zusammenbauen.
Aus Environment-Variablen
oder halt irgendeinen
Library für verwenden.
Also das finde ich
nice. Man sagt den Quarkus
einfach,
also es geht ja zum Beispiel darum,
ich will bestimmte Sachen in meiner
Anwendung von Optionen, die ich setzen
kann, abhängig machen.
Zum Beispiel, welches Verzeichnis
ich hier scannen will
oder in welchem Intervall ich scannen will oder in welchem, ob ich Debug-Logs anzeigen will und sowas.
So, und da gibt es ja verschiedene Varianten, wie man das setzen kann.
Man kann das setzen über eine Config-Datei, man kann das setzen über Command-Line-Parameter,
also was hier, Minus-Minus-Intervall gleich zwei Sekunden,
oder man kann das Ganze über Environment, also Command-Line-Parameter, Environment-Variante oder Config-Datei setzen.
und man muss sich bei Quarkus um nichts kümmern.
Also man definiert einfach, welche Optionen man haben will
und jetzt im Hintergrund guckt er automatisch nach,
gibt es eine Environment-Variable, die hier drauf matcht,
gibt es ein Command-Line-Argument, was hier drauf matcht,
gibt es ein Config-Eintrachter, der hier drauf matcht
und dann mappt er mir das hier rein und wenn es gar nichts gibt, nimmt er den Default Value.
Also das finde ich ist wirklich sehr schick und elegant gemacht. Das gefällt mir.
Das finde ich sehr nice.
Wie bekommt eigentlich Quarkus das hin, dass der Output von Crep refreshed und nichts untereinander steht?
Hä? Was meinst du?
Was meinst du?
Das hier, das hat mit Quarkus nichts zu tun.
Da ist ein Watch davor.
Guck.
Das ist ein Watch, was einen Curl ausführt.
Das macht Watch.
Ja.
Watch alle 0,1 Sekunden.
Was, äh, 0,01 Sekunden.
Ne, 0,1 Sekunden. Was vielleicht
10 Mal pro Sekunde
updaten, vielleicht
jetzt ein bisschen viel des Guten ist.
So.
Also das mit dem
Config Handling
in Quarkus finde ich sehr
nice. Also das gefällt mir von allen
Frameworks, die ich, unabhängig von
Sprache und
alles, ich glaube,
von allen Sachen gefällt mir das
config händling quarkus bisher am besten das ist so schön klar und und wieso so
auch expressive so und es macht halt alles was man haben will weil was willst
du mehr was willst du mehr als kommandozeilen parameter ein weil man
variablen konflikt falls und quarkus kann noch mehr du kannst über 50
verschiedene arten oder 15 verschiedene arten die config sachen setzen ja was
mega nice so und das mit den metriken als hier unten habe das sind prometheus metriken das habe
ich einfach nur eingebaut weil ich gucken wollte wie man das gescheiten quarkus einbaut und das ist
von mir so ein standardtest ich baue ihnen alles gerne prometheus metriken ein um zu gucken wie
das in der jeweiligen sprache so funktioniert weil ich finde das ist immer so ein bisschen
vernachlässigt eine web anwendung bauen generell ist aber eine server anwendung
bauen ist das eine aber der kram und das liegt halt vielleicht auch daran dass
ich so aus dem admin bereich komme anwendung an sich ist ja schön und gut
also richtig nice ist es wenn man das auch ordentlich überwachen kann
womit überwachen meine ich nicht nur dass man gucken kann ob der prozess
läuft oder nicht oder der port office oder nicht dass das kann man schon das
kann man schon seit zeiten von agios aber wenn der anwendung ordentliche
metrics liefert so sachen wie request pro sekunde eingeloggt die user wie
viele fehler bei request und sowas das ist richtig nice um probleme
festzustellen bevor es dann richtig knallt oftmals ist total oft du siehst
du siehst das schon, wenn du ordentliche
Metriken hast,
gepaart mit System
Monitoring zusammen, also mal
angenommen, du hast Metriken von der Anwendung
und du hast, ich sag mal, Metriken von
deinen Servern, ja, sowas wie RAM,
CPU, Disk,
Load und sowas in der Richtung, ja.
Und
wenn du da, also
es ist selten, wie soll ich sagen, es ist selten
so, dass
jetzt ist alles 100%ig in Ordnung
und BÄM, eine Sekunde später ist alles kaputt und alles down.
Das ist meistens nicht so.
Was, Auflösung vom Stream ist bei mir down?
Was?
Verstehe ich nicht.
Das ist ja selten so.
Das ist ja sehr selten so, dass es so von jetzt auf gleich knallt
und dann ist alles weg.
Das zeichnet sich ja meistens ab.
entweder durch laut auf dem server steigt festplatte läuft langsam voll auf dem
server so sachen die die sich andeuten aber man erkennt das auch oftmals an
guten applikationsmetriken also nach dem motto request pro sekunde laufzeit von
request pro sekunde geht oder die laufzeit von request geht übelst hoch
ja normalerweise durchschnittliche response time fünf millisekunden zehn
millisekunden dann geht es hoch auf 30 millisekunden auf 100 millisekunden da
kannst du den ok irgendwas stimmt da nicht und wenn dann zufälligerweise noch
siehst ach guck mal auf den datenbankisten haben wir ja 90 prozent
cpu auslastung auf einmal kannst du kannst schon sagen sagt bei jungs guckt
doch mal jetzt schon bevor es dann vielleicht eine halbe stunde später
komplett kaputt geht also ordentliche metriken zu haben um seine anwendung
überwachen zu können ist finde ich oft bisschen vernachlässigt ist wahrscheinlich die beste
variante für ausfälle schon quasi fixen bevor sie es eigentlich richtige ausfälle werden das
kenne ich das wollte ich mal ausprobieren ja das ist eine message message library
dessen ich schreibe beim neuen job angekommen der jetzt terraform terraform ist nicht verkehrt zu
wissen bei der bank ist es viel ruhiger als bei der dienstleiter das kann ich
mir vorstellen terraform ist nice terraform hat seine eigenheiten zum
beispiel schleifen in terraform sind naja genauso wie schleifen in enzibel
die sind auch naja.
Aber an sich
an sich
ist Terraform schon sehr nice.
Hat seine
Eigenheiten, aber ist
mit Abstand das verbreitetste
IAC Produkt, was es
so gibt. Infrastructure as Code.
Gibt noch ein paar Alternativen.
Gibt noch Pulumi zum Beispiel.
Oder jetzt im Kubernetes
Umfeld Crossplane, wobei ich das
nicht so direkt als konkurrenz sehe eigentlich crossplane ist auch richtig
vor andersherum finde ich finde ich crossplane mega nice crossplane ist
quasi wenn man wenn die terraform kennt ja dann ist crossplane quasi terraform
config als kubernetes jammel custom resource definitions in kubernetes du
kannst ja normalerweise in kubernetes jammel schreibst du so sachen rein wie
ich will ein deployment und das ist meine port config dafür und dann die pläne und raus und
scales auf fünf orts hoch so und das kannst du in kubernetes config in der regel nur halt
kubernetes sachen definieren die was mit kubernetes zu tun haben und cross plane erlaubt
dir eigene resource definitions in kubernetes jammel einzufügen also ich meine dass da das
mit dem Eis am Stiel.
Ja, Crossplane.
Da kannst du eigene Kubernetes
Ressourcen-Typen
anlegen, zum Beispiel eine Cloud-SQL-Datenbank.
Und
Crossplane
ist als Controller, läuft
in einem Kubernetes-Cluster und du kannst
dann einen YAML pushen, wo anstatt
Deployments und Pods und sonst was
drin steht, ich brauche eine
Cloud-SQL-Datenbank.
Und dann schnappt sich
das Crossplane und baut für dich eine Cloud-SQL-Datenbank.
bank auf obwohl es nichts mit kubernetes ressourcen zu tun hat also crossplay ist
eine super neiße geschichte aber auch ziemlich frei fährt und was halt richtig cool ist du
kannst dann zum beispiel für für deine entwickler kannst du eine custom resource definition anlegen
die sich application nennt und die müssen dann einfach nur ausfüllen resource type application
eingangs url und keine ahnung warum war das war's ja eingangs url und container image oder irgendwie
sowas ja müssen die mussten nur noch ausfüllen und unter der haube steckt dann kannst den cross
plan definieren unter der haube steckt dann hinter diesem resource type application in wirklichkeit
https endpunkt in laut balancer eine cloud sql datenbank und sonst was unten drunter was der
dann quasi aufbaut und ein entwickler müssen nur noch definieren applications und das ist
das das ist das container image und das will ich als endpunkt url verwenden also crossplay
ist wirklich sehr feife ich weiß bin ein bisschen ein bisschen seit seit trackt
Hey Max, mal eine persönliche Frage.
Ich mache gerade meinen Bachelor in Informatik und bin 26.
Denkst du, ich sollte nach...
Da kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Master noch ransetzen, eventuell Berufsbekleidung oder ab in die Wirtschaft und was machen.
Arbeite aktuell schon als Werkstatt, könnte wahrscheinlich danach mal abgehen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Also das Einzige, was ich dazu sagen kann, im Durchschnitt verdienen Leute,
je höher der Abschluss ist, im Durchschnitt auch mehr.
so durchschnitt heißt allerdings auch das wusste ich wirklich auf dich zu treffen aber im
durchschnitt kann man sagen ja umso besser dann abschluss ist umso mehr verdienste ob
seine mente wirklich der fall ist einmal hingestellt ich habe nicht studiert und
ich bin auch ganz zufrieden mit meinem gehalt muss musst du dir überlegen ob du dann auch bock hast
Daniel Lull, dankeschön für den Sub.
Übrigens Leute, wenn euch der Stream gefällt,
ich habe mich sehr gefreut, die letzten zwei Streams,
da so viele Follows gegeben hat.
Wenn euch das gefällt, wenn ihr das nächste Mal mit am Start
sein wollt, direkt wieder,
könnt ihr jetzt ja Follow klicken.
Ja, das stimmt.
Also ich kann dir das auch
dann nicht wirklich was zu raten.
so okay jetzt aber mal weiter hier im text genau wir bauen jetzt noch ein paar metriken
ein in unserer anwendung und zwar das ist jetzt bis wie gesagt hier soll keine anwendung raus
kommen die was wirklich sinnvolles macht es geht darum dass man ein bisschen quarkus lernt
So, wir werden jetzt noch ein paar weitere Metriken einführen. Metriken für Page Falls, Minor Major Page Falls, Uptime und dann werden wir meine Lieblingsmetrik einführen, die ich gerne immer in Beispielanwendungen reinbaue. Größe von einem Verzeichnis bereitstellen. Also, gucken wir mal.
lasst mal überlegen wie fangen wir das mit was und wo und wie fangen wir jetzt am besten an
wir legen einfach mal ein paar metriken noch an zur abteilmetrik aber ja auch feine machen
major major page volt metrik machen wir noch meiner page volt metrik da habe ich mal fragen
fragen was er für schmerzen hat ach so weil ich im konstrukt an die
setzte ok macht sinn abteil major page falls so das reicht so und dann machen
wir noch eine nennen wir es mal directory sei es was wir über unsere
application konflikt kriegen kann man kann man auch setzen welches verzeichnis
man überwachen will directory sei es metrik dann legen wir das mal an base
units milliseconds muss man kurz gucken in welche einheit major page falls sind unter linux sind
das sind das in bytes moment warum ist das auf deutsch das habe ich auch nicht dass die deutsche
band page als erstes kommt major page falls namen auf major number okay es ist als es quasi eine art
Counter. Ja.
Okay.
Ich werde aber trotzdem als Metrik
keinen Counter verwenden, weil
Counter dürfen, sagt zumindest die
Prometheus-Spec, nur
steigen.
Wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe.
Und wenn ein Prozess neu gestartet wird, dann
kann es durchaus sein, dass der
sinkt.
So.
Also dann brauchen wir hier noch eine Metrik für meiner PageFalls.
Machen wir es mal genau so.
Und dann brauchen wir noch eine Metrik für, nennen wir es mal DirectorySize.
BaseUnit ist würde ich sagen Bytes.
Gibt es nicht?
Bytes, doch.
Genau, zack.
Fertig.
Jetzt ist das angelegt.
So, und jetzt, jetzt machen wir es mal ordentlich, Leute.
Jetzt gucken wir uns das hier mal an, weil das ist super weird.
Das kann kein Mensch lesen.
Und ich verstehe wahrscheinlich selbst in zwei Wochen,
oder in zwei Tagen nicht mehr, was ich hier gemacht habe.
Wir machen jetzt mal so, wie ich denke, dass man es ordentlich macht in Java.
Wie gesagt, ich bin kein großer Java-Checker.
Also hier gucken wir ja.
Hier scannen wir ja die laufenden Prozesse auf unserem Linux.
Wir gucken uns im Endeffekt alle Prozesse an, filtern die Prozesse nach dem Namen.
Also wir gucken, ob der Name, der über die Config gesetzt ist, eben gleich dem Prozessname ist.
Und wenn wir keinen Prozess finden, der dem Namen entspricht, dann gibt es eine IO-Exception.
Eigentlich auch nicht so richtig, wenn man es mal genau nimmt.
weil es hat ja mit Ionics zu tun aber wen juckt's und hier bauen wir dann unsere Metrik zusammen.
Das finde ich ist schlecht lesbar deswegen versuchen wir das jetzt mal ein bisschen
ordentlich zu machen. Also wir machen jetzt erstmal habe ich mir so gedacht eine Klasse
die nennen wir mal so was wie prozess scanner oder so was in der richtung also klasse public
class process scanner so das muss ich jetzt in der andere datei verschieben sonst meckerte
aber wir glauben uns hier schon mal die methode draus dass das hier lassen wir mal ich weiß dass
es kaputt ist fixen wir gleich so process gerne wie können wir das jetzt bauen das ist
das ist eine statische methode weil ab dann nichts was irgendwie instanz mäßig was braucht
geld process ins wo das werden wir feind groß warum will ich brauchst also sind wir mit cc
schreiben feind process string name ist okay exception wird wahrscheinlich auch für 20
aufpassen. So.
Zurück
gibt es eine List
von Prozessen.
Gibt es
in Java sowas wie
IEnamorable...
Oh, da war noch sowas.
Nee, gibt's nicht.
IEnamoration?
So.
Oder was benutzt man da so als
Collection?
Was benutzt man da so als Base-Type?
Wenn man nicht direkt die Liste zurückgeben will.
Warum wollen die jetzt irgendwelche Bilder?
Ja war Gegenstück zu I in the name of T.
Wenn ich das richtig schreiben könnte.
Mal gucken, ob das Chat-GPT checkt.
Iterable.
Aha.
Okay.
Ja, dann machen wir das doch mal.
E-Terrible
OS-Process.
So, wie machen wir das jetzt ordentlich?
Also, war Systeminfo
gleich
Java Streams?
Das müssen wir uns gleich mal angucken, ob wir das nicht auch schöner machen können.
Hups, wenn ich das mal richtig schreiben könnte.
Systeminfo
New
OSHI
System Info FFM.
Was auch immer das mit Frankfurt zu tun hat,
habe ich bis heute noch nicht gecheckt.
System Info.
Dann holen wir uns...
Im Prinzip wollen wir dann das da machen.
System Info.
Get Operating System.
Processes, genau.
Get Processes.
Stream.
Will ich das wirklich so...
Ja doch, das können wir schon so lassen.
Get Operating System, get Processes.
Dann machen wir doch jetzt hier einfach mal so.
get processes und jetzt sagen wir hier filtert gleich da wird das nicht so
lang bros warum will ich process immer mit cc schreiben
so processes stream filter und dann tool ist auch gut so ich will nicht ab konflikt sondern name
das noch so untereinander schreiben dann gucken wir filtert ist empty
dann gibt es hier prozessen und ansonsten returnen wir filtert so da können wir doch
doch jetzt schon ein bisschen aufräumen zwar kann man unseren background ab später sagen
process scanner punkt find processes
sind wir die methode hier los und haben die bisschen besser gekapselt
so jetzt ist die große preisfrage wie machen wir das jetzt hier mit den metriken weil das
sieht irgendwie irgendwie sieht das eklig aus wir machen mal so was wir machen mal so was in
der richtung hier. void, create, process, metrics und dann versuchen wir das mal
bisschen besser lesbar zu machen.
was meint ihr chat?
FFM ist einfach Bleeding Edge Technology.
Du meinst Bleeding Edge wegen den ganzen Messerleuten am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof?
Das FFM in Oschi.
Ach, Foreign Function Memory.
Ach so.
Da wäre ich jetzt nicht drauf gekommen, dass das Foreign Function Memory ist.
Kann aber durchaus sein.
Wobei ich bei ChatGPT immer skeptisch bin, ob sich das nicht irgendwas dazu halluziniert.
Ja, und sorry Leute, ich weiß, blöde Uhrzeit zu streamen, aber geht nicht anders.
So, also weiter im Text. Jetzt machen wir mal so viel. Create Process Metrics. Dort übergeben wir jetzt das eigentliche Prometheus Metric Objekt und wir übergeben eine, wie war das? Iterable von Prozessen.
so
jetzt gucken wir mal, ob wir diesen Mist hier irgendwie
ausgelagert kriegen
das Logging
das schmeiß ich mal
schmeiß ich mal kurz weg
auskommentieren
dass ich dann überhaupt nicht selbst noch in der Woche durchblicke
so, wie funzt
das jetzt, also das da kommt auch weg
so, wie funzt das jetzt, das hier brauchen
war also kommt das weg so am endeffekt was will ich denn was will ich denn am ende schreiben am
ende will ich schreiben so was wie create metric dann übergebe ich hier zum beispiel diese abteilen
abzeichen matrix übrigens ich muss sagen ich finde das mit dem bis davor immer noch blöd ich glaube
ich schwenke auch bei java um auf anders vor privaten variablen das will ich übergeben und
process das will ich übergeben so und dann soll er mir die metrics hier ordentlich filmen so ab
zwei metrik major page volt metrik meiner page volt metrik sondern soll er mir das zusammenbauen
in der hoffnung dass das so funktioniert wie ich mir das gedacht habe wie machen wir das denn jetzt
hier ich kak nu ich habe sekunde wartet mal kurz das hier das hier muss man merken dass das das
will ich mir nie wieder gescheit zusammenbauen können sonst so create process metrik wir
returnen wir die teilen gar nichts wir
returnen gar nichts jetzt kommt jetzt
kommt pfeiffer teil wie marien das jetzt
gescheit also das hier ist ja immer
gleich und moment so machen wir das also
war, jetzt wollen wir mal mappt,
Processes.
Leute, wenn ich für jeden...
Ach, das kann man nicht streamen?
Was zum Teufel ist ein Splitterator?
Hört sich ein bisschen an wie ein Dinosaurier.
Kann man Iterable nicht
streamen?
Da muss ich bestimmt Collection
nehmen, oder?
Stream. Ja, okay, das geht.
Splitterator.
So.
Das Mappen.
Mapp?
So.
Process.
Jetzt muss ich das irgendwie hier zusammenbauen.
Das wird eklig.
So, das
kommt dahin wie jetzt moment moment das ist das syntaktisch richtig was ich hier
gebaut habe das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht
nicht schlecht auch wenn es eklig aussieht tags of können theoretisch auch
noch hier oben hinschreiben. Und dann machen wir das
einfach immer pro
Zeile. Ja, das kann man...
Ich glaube, das kann man jetzt eigentlich ganz gut lesen.
Gut.
Jetzt können wir hier... Nee, können wir nicht.
Alter, ich bin ja auch doof.
Ich setze hier ja drinnen hardcoded
die Prozess-Uptime. Ich will ja gar
nicht die Prozess-Uptime setzen. Ich will ja hier...
Was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen?
Okay, iterable ist
verkehrt. Wir wollen
Collection. Okay.
Ich will ja hier einmal die Major Page Falls, Minor Page Falls und Uptime setzen.
Da kann ich nicht immer hardcoded die Uptime nehmen.
Ich bräuchte jetzt sowas.
Okay, Five Head Time.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die richtige Syntax ist.
Aber wir können sowas machen wie Map Function.
Also im Prinzip sowas.
Oh, gibt es das hier?
es heißt sogar Function
genau das habe ich gesucht
ich wollte eigentlich gerade schreiben
in C Sharp
hätte ich jetzt sowas hier gemacht
Funk
of OS Process
und Long
oder so
und dann kann man quasi ein Callback übergeben
an die Funktion
also anscheinend ist das hier aber
es heißt Function
Warum gibt es Function?
Was? Function 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9?
What?
Function.
So.
Function. Und da will ich jetzt sowas wie
OS Process
und Long.
Hab ich jetzt irgendwas verschoben aus Versehen gerade?
Ich glaube nicht, oder?
So.
Function.
Map Function.
Schauen wir mal, ob das so funzt.
So, und jetzt würde ich hier sagen,
Map Function.
Wie geht das jetzt?
Apply.
Wahrscheinlich.
Prozess.
Okay, das funzt.
Jetzt muss ich hier
sagen, wie gemappt werden soll.
Also.
Get
Uptime.
Was will er
jetzt von mir?
Replace Lambda with Method Reference.
Okay. Ja, aber im Prinzip
will ich genau das haben.
Ich hier get uptime,
get major pagefalls,
get minor pagefalls.
So, das kommt weg.
Ja, das ist doch, Leute, das ist ja
jetzt schon mal deutlich besser lesbar, als
diesen Krempel, den ich davor fabriziert habe, oder?
So, jetzt kommen hier noch die
die Logs.
Da müssen wir einmal eine Schleife machen.
Processes.
Das ist für die Logs.
Das kann man jetzt ja sogar richtig lesen, Mann.
Was ist da los?
Das ist jetzt tatsächlich...
Also muss man echt sagen, das ist jetzt wirklich ganz gut lesbar.
Kann man sich ja beschweren.
man erkennt sogar was passiert ja hier create process metrics für abzeichen für major page
falls um einer page falls wenn ich jetzt noch eine weitere mit trägt bräuchte könnte ich einfach
kopieren und runterhauen das doch nicht schlecht so next jetzt brauchen wir noch metriken für ordner
ordner größe
Da machen wir, würde ich sagen, genau das gleiche, oder?
Wie machen wir das jetzt?
Moment, wir brauchen erstmal
Überhaupt die
Die Funktion, wie ich
Das haben wir doch letztens programmiert, Leute
Das können wir uns da klauen
Repos
Vakus-Champ, Sigmetrix-Champ
Hier
Wo haben wir hier zuletzt
Java-Champ, Kekw-Champ
Irgendwo hier haben wir doch
ausgelesen
Ordnergröße.
Ausgerechnet.
Alter, diese 30.000
Unterordner bei Java. Ey, da fuck.
Java-Projekten, da hätte ich mich nie dran
gewöhnen können.
Ne, das war Springboot
Gedöns.
Ne.
Wir haben das doch irgendwo gemacht
Wir haben doch irgendwo in Java ausgelesen
Wie groß ein Verzeichnis ist
Bin ich jetzt
Oder bin ich dumm
Und das haben wir nicht gemacht
Na gut
Ich war in dem Zweifelsfall
Wir können es uns auch
Wir können es uns auch irgendwie zusammen reiten
Was haben wir gemacht
Ich weiß aber nicht mehr wo
Welchem Stream?
In Go haben wir es auch gemacht und danach wollte ich es nochmal in Java machen.
Oder ich habe nur geguckt, wie es geht und...
Hier ist es ja offensichtlich nicht drin.
Boah, Alter.
Vom
Juli.
23.
Nee.
Das ist es garantiert nicht.
Wo könnte ich das denn hin haben?
.NET 10 Champ?
Das kann nicht sein.
Der Monitoring Champ?
Ah, hier.
Hier.
Source.
Java.
Keck W.
Das ist so krass, diese 1000 Unterordner.
Cut. Monitoring Champ.
Hier.
Da haben wir es doch.
Ihr sei es
Was follow links warum wir wollen doch gar keinen links verloren
Web tour
Ok wisst ihr was ich ich gucke ein bisschen ab hier aber ich kopiere mir das nicht einfach
also da machen wir doch wir haben ja gesagt heute wir machen es ordentlich ich kopiere mir das mal
so wir machen jetzt sicher und prozess gerne machen noch ein directory scanner der scanna
so dass hier kommt weg so also was wollen wir was was brauchen wir denn für methoden da drin
wir brauchen sowas wie
äh gut hier
das
OS Process schon mal nett
also wir brauchen sowas wie
get size
get size in bytes
machen wir mal von einem Ordner
so und das ist ja hier
ein Path
so
ok
so wie ging das
jetzt nochmal
irgendwas mit walk war das stand das nicht stand das nicht hier irgendwie trainer auf heils walk
Das ist aber ziemlich blöd, wie ich das damals programmiert habe, weil guck mal, sobald
eine IOR-Exception auftritt, weil
irgendwie File gelockt ist oder sonst was,
dann kackt der klar ab.
Das ist nicht so schlau gewesen,
was ich da gebaut habe. Dann bauen wir das
nochmal neu. Also,
wie kriege ich die
Größe von einem
Verzeichnis raus in Java?
Also, get
size in bytes. Es ist auf jeden Fall
files.walk. Das ist schon mal
sinnvoll.
Und zwar in dem Path, den wir
hier übergeben haben. Da müssen wir jetzt
ein Triad rummachen, habe ich gelernt.
Keine Ahnung.
War.
Borg. Wie nennt man das denn hier?
Warum?
Müssen wir dann ein Triad
rummachen?
Ah, weil es ein Stream ist.
Okay, verstehe.
so geht es also als punkt walk geht jede datei und jedes verzeichnis und jedes unterverzeichnis
und unter unterverzeichnis in einem pfad durch also dass das kommt quasi an jeder datei egal
wie tief nestet in unterverzeichnissen mal vorbei gut das heißt wir sagen jetzt hier
files work jetzt müssen wir gucken genau jetzt müssen wir schauen ob regular
file genau das muss man machen also filter
ähm, File,
Regular,
ne, wie, wie ging das hier?
Files ist Regular File,
okay.
also wir wollen keine Verzeichnisse,
wir wollen ja wirklich nur,
jede Datei, egal in wie viel
Monteverzeichnis sie drin ist, wollen wir jede Datei
einmal vorbeikommen und uns die Größe holen.
Also,
Filter,
Is regular file.
So.
Map.
Map to long.
Das hatten wir hier glaube ich auch.
So.
Map to long.
Und das habe ich gelesen.
Das soll man nicht mehr machen.
File to length.
Sondern man soll jetzt direkt diese neue File API verwenden.
Deswegen machen wir jetzt.
long jetzt es war doch irgendwie so feier sei es ja genau falls sei es
irgendwie so oder jetzt jetzt mag er nicht warum nicht weil es hat dafür
schmerzen 3 surround with cats ist der eklig aus monka es wir können das
Return, wenn wir es richtig gemacht haben.
Nee, können wir nicht.
Wann macht Max seine Wubblorslang?
Wubblang.
Wubblang würde ich dann machen.
Oder Maxlang.
Nee, dazu wird es nicht kommen.
Main.wub
Also, Punkt Wub wäre aber
eine gute Dateiendung, oder?
Also das würde mir gefallen.
So, was passiert denn,
wenn ich
einen Fehler,
eine I.O. Exception
kriege beim Zugreifen, dann
weiß ich, was passiert.
dann will ich
return
zurück. Das haben wir hier nämlich auch.
Ne, machen wir hier gar nicht.
Genau.
Ich gebe 0 zurück.
Passt.
Okay, und dann returnen wir das einfach.
Ach ne.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Punkt sum
brauchen wir noch.
Und jetzt? Was hat er?
Ach, return long.
Okay, das passt doch, das ergibt doch jetzt Sinn.
Also wir gehen in das Verzeichnis rein, gehen jede einzelne Unterdatei durch,
gucken, ob die Datei eine normale Datei ist.
Wenn es eine normale, also wir filtern alles raus, was nicht eine normale Datei ist.
dann gehen wir jeden Eintrag durch und gucken wie groß die Datei ist. Wenn es
irgendwie Probleme gibt beim Auslesen der Datei, dann geben wir einfach 0 Bytes
zurück. So und am Ende rechnen wir alle Größen von allen Dateien im Unterordner
zusammen das müsste doch eigentlich so so passen
weil ich sage das kann man aber ausprobieren das kann man mal ausprobieren
also machen wir mal hier log info und wie habe ich das ding land directory
scanner get size in bytes app config data dir ach ne moment wie war das path path of oder sowas
ok so jetzt gibt es hier einmal pro sekunde gibt es jetzt hier ein log eintrag mit size in bytes
von dem Verzeichnis.
Aber guck mal, nee, das kann ja eine
I.O. Exception werfen.
Aha.
Moment, Moment, Moment. Das kann ja eine I.O.
Exception werfen, also muss ich theoretisch
das noch
catch. Wobei, ich catch
das ja hier unten. Passt.
Okay.
Ach, guck mal hier.
No such file exception
Slash Data. Na, dann machen wir das doch mal.
Dann machen wir das doch mal. Gehen wir mal hier hin.
MKDia Slash Data.
Mal gucken, was jetzt passiert.
Achso.
Ich bin nicht gut.
MKDia Slash Data.
Der Fehler ist weg.
message 0 ja gut 0 passt ja auch in den verzeichnis ist ja nichts drin so gehen wir
jetzt mal in das gehen wir jetzt mal hier rein was gleich städter mkd er keck w nach keck wg
bereien mkd nun dort sind im zweiten dritten unterverzeichnis und jetzt legen wir da eine
datei an was wir bis nicht installiert
wenn wir diese datei will ich unbedingt anlegen mit diesem inhalt ist den
inhalt den wollte schon immer haben
und hier zu blöd für 194 und wie zeigt man sich die bytes
Okay, whatever
Gucken wir mal
Doch, 194 Bytes
194 Bytes
Ist die Datei groß
Oder das gesamte Verzeichnis
Ist 194 Bytes groß
Können wir nochmal checken
Ich gehe jetzt nochmal eins hoch
Kopiere mir das Lullverzeichnis nach
Blub
So, jetzt müssen wir das Doppelte haben.
Genau, 388.
Okay, das funktioniert, was ich hier gebastelt habe.
Wir können jetzt auslesen, wie groß ist ein Verzeichnis.
Okay, gut.
So, als nächstes.
Oh, jetzt kommt Fifehead-Time.
Ich brauche hier nicht nur GetSizeInBytes.
Nennen wir das mal GetDirectorySizeInBytes.
Achso, warte mal.
Machen wir das hier mal weg gerade.
Aber das ist glaube ich sinnvoller, wenn es GetDirectorySizeInBytes heißt.
Da kann man sich besser was drunter vorstellen.
So, wir brauchen jetzt ja allerdings nicht nur GetDirectorySizeInBytes.
wir brauchen das jetzt ja
nochmal für ein Verzeichnis
und die Unterverzeichnisse. Also, was ich
machen will ist ja, wenn wir uns
das jetzt mal hier angucken,
hier gibt es ja
was weiß ich,
hier gibt es ja jetzt mehrere Unterverzeichnisse.
So, und ich will jetzt für jedes
Unterverzeichnis in diesem Delta-Verzeichnis
einen Metrikeintrag
machen, wie groß es ist.
Also, wir brauchen jetzt quasi noch einmal eine Schleife
über die oberste ebene von den verzeichnissen da machen wir so man eine funktion in public
static ich weiß noch nicht was für eine return wert und das ding heißt jetzt geht
sei es auf all
directories
Factory Manager Observer.
Jetzt ist es richtig Enterprise, oder?
So, wie machen wir das jetzt?
Hier gibt es wieder einen Pfad, würde ich sagen.
So, also, jetzt muss ich mal denken.
Wir wollen jetzt auf jeden Fall so etwas wie Files List.
Nicht Walk.
Wollen wir die Files Lists in dem Path haben.
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Übrigens sehr nice.
IntelliJ ist wieder kaputt.
Unhandled Exception.
Ja.
Nervt nicht.
So, da muss ich jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder
einen Try drumherum machen
Try
War, ja, Directories
oder so
Wobei, sind das überhaupt Directories?
Ja, ich muss noch filtern
Ich muss filtern nach
Ähm
Files
IsDirectory
Okay
So, jetzt habe ich alle Verzeichnisse, also alle direkten Unterverzeichnisse bekomme ich jetzt.
Und jetzt will ich quasi diese Funktion aufrufen für jedes der Unterverzeichnisse, sodass ich am Ende eine Map kriege mit allen Unterverzeichnissen drinnen.
Also, Directories.
Äh, Toolist oder so.
Toolist.
machen wir mal eine Schleife drüber.
Directory.
So.
Mal gucken, ob das die schönste Variante ist,
wie wir es machen können.
So, jetzt machen wir eine Schleife
über die Directories.
Und für jedes
Directory rufen wir jetzt
das da auf.
directory size in bytes genau
directory size in bytes so und das ganze wollen wir in der hash map packen dass wir
Key das Verzeichnis haben
und
Value die Größe in
Bytes von dem Verzeichnis.
Also machen wir hier irgendwie sowas wie
Result oder so.
New
Hash Map
Ausfahrt
und
Long.
Was ich
immer noch nicht so genau gecheckt
habe ist, warum ich
einen Long nicht in eine Map packen kann,
aber einen Long großgeschrieben schon.
Warum es zweimal das gleiche braucht?
Das hat bestimmt irgendwas mit Stack Allocation
und Heap Allocation oder irgendwie sowas zu tun.
Ich war es denn.
So.
Jetzt haben wir hier
äh, sagen wir mal
size
und dann sagen wir
result put
directory
und size
da rein und am
Ende
returnen wir result.
So, soweit so gut eigentlich.
Das müsste doch passen.
Ne, das passt nicht,
weil hier könnte es ja eine exception geben und wenn es eine exception gibt
dann will ich ja nicht gleich abbrechen
also das heißt long kann null sein und klein long nicht
Also mit 0 meine ich jetzt 0.
Nicht die Zahl.
Ah, das ist jetzt eklig.
Jetzt muss ich ja noch ein Try Catch oder so drumherum machen.
Try.
Das da.
Catch.
IO Exception.
Ja, und wenn das eine IO Exception ist,
dann machen wir einfach gar nichts.
Irgendwie so.
Was will er denn?
Ich dachte, man darf es so machen. Warum darf man nicht so machen?
Chatgeber, was ist da los?
Unnamed Pattern are not supported at language level 21.
Ach.
Unser Language Level stimmt nicht.
Ich dachte, wir haben 25.
aber nicht wo ist das denn definiert überhaupt welches language level wir
haben ja erst mal level up xml
ach hier guck mal das was anderes oder maven compiler release
level
Ist es vielleicht doch das?
Schreiben wir mal hier 25 rein.
Mal gucken, was dann passiert.
Hey, das war's?
Ha!
Das war's?
Pfeiffer?
Hat das jetzt irgendwelche negativen Auswirkungen?
Weil ein Default scheint ja 21 zu sein.
Vielleicht gibt es irgendwelche Sachen, die noch nicht unterstützt werden von Quarkus.
aber das kann ich sagen das ist ja rückwärts kompatibel das sollte eigentlich kein problem
sein so also weiter im text exception jetzt kann auf jeden fall hier so schreiben gut das
müsste eigentlich so passen leute glaubt das kann man so lassen ich habe eine idee moment
Jetzt, jetzt kann ich mal meine Java-Skills checken
Wartet mal
Wir machen das gleiche nochmal
Nur, dass ich das jetzt versuche, nur mit der Stream-API zu lösen, okay?
Also jetzt nicht hier irgendwie Schleife drüber
Nur mit Stream-API
Okay, schauen wir mal
Schauen wir mal, schauen wir mal
Ich mache mal wieder Void, weil ich nicht sicher bin, wie es...
Aber nur aus Spaß. Weiß ich nicht, vielleicht sieht es am Ende sogar lesbarer aus. Keine Ahnung.
Okay, also.
Directories.
Okay, das müssen wir auf jeden Fall so machen.
Das geht nicht anders.
Oder?
Kann ich jetzt...
Nee, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Aber ich kann das doch jetzt nicht alles da reinschreiben, oder?
machen das so.
So, okay. So lassen wir es.
Directories ist doch gut.
So, und jetzt
okay, das kommentieren wir mal aus.
Und jetzt sagen wir
Directories
ähm
Map
Irgendwie sowas. Map
Map Directory
Und dann das da rein
Ne, das funzt ja nicht
Das funzt ja
Ah, Moment, Moment
Das ist tatsächlich komplizierter, als ich mir das gedacht habe
Das funzt nicht
Weil
Ich kann das hier zwar returnen
aber ich muss ja für jeden fahrt hierauf muss ich irgendwas returnen das heißt ein optionales
weglassen geht ja gar nicht mit map also ich kann jetzt der sagte hier musste return missing genau
so aber weil ich will aber ich will ja sachen die exception werfen beim bereits berechnen wegen was
auch immer die will ich ja gar nicht im output drin haben so wie macht man das jetzt am besten
wir fragen mal chat gpt wir fragen wir mal ein lokales
Kann es ja null geben? Du meinst... Ah! Moment, so quasi.
Ah ja. Eigentlich gar keine schlechte Idee.
Aber das ist verkehrt. Moment, Moment, Moment. Das ist verkehrt. Das bringt nichts.
das geht nicht weil ich will ich will ja nicht ich will ja gar nicht den die
beiz ich will ja ein key value per im endeffekt haben mit fahrt gibt es gibt
das so was wie die value pair
kuppel
aha
map
Da war Key Value Pair Class in Standard Lib.
There is no single universal Key Value Pair Class, but there are several.
Map Entry, Standard Key Value Pair.
Okay.
Okay, heißt...
Wie war das jetzt?
Map of...
Gibt es sowas wie Map.Entry?
Ach ja, guck mal.
Map.Entry?
So, das wird der Pfad und das da als Value.
ok
heißt wenn das so und jetzt und jetzt filter ich
filter
die value per
schön ist es aber nett
Ungleich 0
Objects non-null
Macht das Sinn?
Ist das das, was ich will?
Ja, oder?
so und wie kriege ich daraus jetzt eine
eine hash map gebaut
java stream ap
to hash
collectors to map
collect collectors to map also heißt
heißt collect collectors und das ist das ja wieder hier high iq shit und und und dann sowas
wie kann ich ja nicht einfach das key value per das key value per übergeben und gutes
die value per get key value per value ok
Ups
Reformat
Okay
Das müsste jetzt genau das sein
Was ich haben will und das returnen wir jetzt
Ah ja
Okay, gut
So, Chat, ihr entscheidet
Was ist
Was ist schöner
Was ist besser
Das da
Oder das da
Im Prinzip ist es mehr oder weniger ähnlich lang.
Also ich finde ja.
Also einfacher zu lesen finde ich das unten ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, ich auch.
Das da oben mag zwar moderner und cooler sein.
Aber besser lesbar ist das hier, oder?
Ja.
Ich meine, hier ist klar, was passiert.
Es gibt eine Result-Hash-Map.
Wir gehen alle
Directories durch.
Wir machen Mix,
wenn es... Das ist schon
klarer, oder?
Als das da oben.
Das da oben ist...
Ich glaube, dass da oben
die...
die krassen Java-Kenner
die werden wahrscheinlich sagen, das obere ist besser.
Weil die sofort wissen, was da passiert.
Ja.
Letztendlich kommt das gleiche bei rum.
Also ist egal.
Da kommt genau das gleiche bei raus.
Aber wir haben wieder was gelernt.
Komm, wir behalten das.
Wir behalten das.
Wir behalten einfach beides.
Kann ich nochmal abgucken in Zukunft.
Okay.
Dann weiter im Text.
Der Tri-Block im Stream ist kacke.
Ich glaube, das braucht man.
Kann man das weglassen?
Ich glaube nicht.
Der meckert nämlich, wenn ich das weglasse.
Guck, wenn ich hier den Tri-Block weglasse.
dann meckert er hier über
Used without try.
Deswegen.
Den Sinn verstehe ich.
Das ist, dass es ein automatisches Close macht.
Versuch mal Inline.
Wie?
Was?
Was Inline?
Was meinst du?
also du meinst das direkt hinten dran
er meckert immer noch aber also mich fakt echt ab dass intelligence oft kaputt geht
letzter zeit mag er nicht just without trial statement
naja wir lassen wir lassen es einfach so
gut also dann gehen wir mal hier weiter zu unserem background ab ab data operation ist
sowieso flüchtig sagt der chat ja weil dann weil das quasi so eine art finally block mit
einem Klaus drin hat, oder?
Das finde ich übrigens in C Sharp ganz nett.
In C Sharp würdest du
schreiben
using
Wenn ich das richtig schreiben könnte.
Ich muss echt gar nicht schreiben.
In C Sharp
würdest du so schreiben.
wird es das schreiben und dieses using sorgt dafür dass es das post bzw geklopft wird automatisch auch
wenn es fehler gibt ich glaube mittlerweile gibt es sogar auch so abgedrehte sachen wie
sowas hier in sich habe weil ich so gut wie nie verwendet aber sie haben tatsächlich schon ein
paar ganz gute sachen eingebaut die microsoft leute soll ich okay ich fragte gpt ob man das
hier schöner machen kann wir fragen wir fragen mal was ist eigentlich das normale model was
man hier bekommt wenn man nicht eingeloggt ist habt ihr eine ahnung was das ist oder wo man
das sehen kann welches chat gpt model verwende ich das können die dinge an dem wir sind oder
5.2
ok
kann man das hier schöner machen in java
ja das kann man lesbare idiomatischer und robuste schreiben dein aktueller
code ein paar typische gerüchte
0 als fehlerersatz im stream exception handling im map etwas schwer zu lesen
durch verschachtelte landes okay ich zeigt jetzt bin ich mal gespannt jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt was es hier raushaut klar und sauber empfohlen variante exception handling außerhalb
des streams viel besser lesbar moment moment exception handling außerhalb des streams der
macht einfach überhaupt kein exception handling der lässt es einfach weg
er macht gar keine exception handling
Ja gut, der Return...
Nee, nee, nee, das ist nicht
äquivalent zu meinem.
Ja, das ist nicht das gleiche.
Meiner macht weiter bei einer
IO-Exception.
Das ist nicht das gleiche, was der hier macht.
Der bricht ab
bei der ersten IO-Exception.
Ich mach weiter.
Lösung ohne Null.
Funktional, aber sauber.
Filter.
Collect.
To map.
What?
Das funktioniert nicht.
Chat, ich...
Ich glaube, das funktioniert nicht.
Weil hier
returnnt der nix.
Naja.
Ganz ehrlich.
Scheiß drauf. Mal einfach weiter.
Wir haben jetzt
zwei varianten ja geht klar ok also weiter im text gut genug denke ich auch so also weiter im text
mama hier war sei es direktor ist gerne get size of all sub directories path hier davon so jetzt
haben wir hier unsere habe ich dann noch eine klammer und jetzt brauchen wir so
was wie sowas wieder oben nur für nur für die directory matrix weil ich
kopieren wir das mal. Create, Directory Matrix. Nur dass ich da keine Map Funktion brauche ich
da auch nicht, glaube ich zumindest. So Collection, ich will keine Collection haben, sondern eine Map.
Eine Map
of
Path
und Long.
Ja.
Irgendwie so.
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Map.
so das brauchen wir jetzt einfach mal das schmeißen das schmeißen wir hier klein wieder raus
sei es so lass mal überlegen wie machen wir das jetzt damit bis
des creates direkt die matrix so wir übergeben hier directory sei es moment
wir benennen das Ding mal kurz um. Das Ding heißt
SeltriSizeMetric.
Ja, so.
Gut. Und dann übergeben wir hier
die Sizes.
Dann loggen wir noch das hier.
Sagen wir hier wie logInfoV
new directory info values oder sowas kv info wir haben das hier oben gemacht genau kv info
und dann loggen wir direkt die map so jetzt müssen wir nur noch das für unsere metrics
bauen das herr unten kann weg das war das nur hier für unsere matrix bauen also das kann ja
mehr oder weniger ähnlich wie das da oben sein nur dass wir jetzt sagen müssen sei es stream
Ach, das geht ja nicht.
Entry Set.
Stream. Map.
So.
Entry.
So, Multi.
Row Off.
Und jetzt eigentlich nur
Path.
Nennen wir das Path.
Get Key.
und die Pit und sowas, das brauchen wir gar nicht.
Ja.
Was hab ich falsch gemacht?
Boah, diese, die, die,
1000, 1000
Klammer-Shit, ey.
Was, was hat der für Schmerzen?
Cannot resolve method of string pass.
Ah.
Pass to String muss ich machen.
Oder auch nicht.
Wo ist das Problem?
Irgendwas habe ich verkackt.
Warte mal.
Ey, was will der von mir?
Warum geht das nicht?
Wo ist hier
falsch?
Ähm.
Ist doch richtig so.
Warte mal.
Bonkers.
E.getValue
Okay, was hat er denn hier?
Ich muss doch da
einfach nur toString sagen, oder?
Easy! Hatte ich das nicht eben schon mal?
Okay.
So, und jetzt sagen wir hier
und register
mapped
true
Wait a minute
Aha, das habe ich hier oben vergessen, guck mal
Wenn ich es mir so recht
angucke, was will er?
Achso, Moment
To list
müssen wir noch machen
Das muss ich auch noch machen, to list
Und dann
Sonst wird es nicht
funzen
Okay
Ja, wunderbar
Leute, da muss man sagen
Das haben wir jetzt ja schön refactored.
Das kann man jetzt wirklich lesen.
Das hier auch.
Das ist gerade einmal so übel.
Nicht verkehrt.
Jetzt ist nur noch die Preisfrage.
funktioniert das denn auch was ich gebaut habe also nicht dass ich es kaputt gemacht habe oder so
Ja, ja, Matrix, Funzen, Proc und wie habe ich das andere genannt? Proc Directory. Okay,
Okay, machen wir mal ein E-Grab.
Proc.
Oder
Directory.
Oh.
Was? Achso.
Quoten.
Ja, passt.
Guck mal.
Dateigröße.
Data Kekkel.
So, jetzt ist die Frage.
Pass mal auf, wenn ich jetzt hier...
Lass mal gucken, ob der das auch ordentlich updatet.
Wenn ich jetzt hier Lull lösche, verschwindet es dann.
Dann verschwindet es auch hier.
Okay, MKDir, blub.
Ist jetzt da.
So, und jetzt erstellen wir hier eine Datei drin.
Jetzt sollte das Verzeichnis gleich, sobald ich gespeichert habe,
größer haben.
vorher hat das übrigens eine größe weil es temp files angelegt hat das funktioniert das ist auch
nice exzellent leute oder ex ex exzellent ex ex exzellent jetzt dreht er komplett durch vorbei
spielte
bist du ja war experte lebenslauf ist schon aktualisiert
Aber ich würde sagen, das können wir so lassen. So, next. Hab ja gesagt, ich will mal gucken,
wie man ein http-client in Quarkus verwendet. Also, dann würde ich sagen, passt soweit.
Der Lebenslauf updatest sich von selbst.
Per AI am besten noch.
KI-Lebenslauf.
So.
Wie benutzt man HTTP-Clients in Quarkus?
Quarkus HTTP-Client.
Using the REST-Client.
How to consume REST-API.
Ah, Blähungen wieder.
consuming api with rest client
was ist das defining client interface register client
interface
Okay, wir nehmen wieder diese To-Do-API.
Das ist ein guter Beispiel-Service hier.
Das da, To-Dos.
Also, wie geht das jetzt?
Moment, ich lese mal kurz hier die offizielle Quarkus-Doku dazu durch.
Also wir brauchen auf jeden Fall Rest Client.
Was brauchen wir? Rest Client Jackson.
Quarkus Rest Client.
ok also müssen wir wieder extensions hinzufügen
machen wir mal cd cd workspaces
rest client
Quarkus REST Client has been installed.
Okay.
Ok.
So.
Konsum AP.
Moment, das ist die falsche Seite.
REST Client.
ich hoffe mal dass der
ich hoffe mal dass der rest klein jason support hat das weil ohne jason support ist ziemlich pp
setting up the model extension ok komm machen wir mal eine klasse das glaube ich gar nicht
so schlecht dafür der klasse für diese to do's to do's dass ihr user id wir machen den rekord
rekord machen wir da public records du item und wir brauchen was ein user id ein int id
ein string title titler und ein bool completed so na gut das müssen wir in der eigenen datei
verschieben sonst mecker da perfekt so weiter geht's create the interface register rest client
Was? Set Extent?
Was?
Ein Set? Achso.
Ah, weil es mehrere zurück...
Warum ein Set?
Es kommt genau eine...
ein...
ein To-Do zurück.
Query Parameters?
Also Query Parameters brauche ich nicht.
ich brauche sowas für den fahrt sein query parameter form parameter path
parameter das brauche ich hier kopieren wir das mal
get by stream
Wo ist hier der path? Ach hier ist der path Parameter.
Ah ja.
Okay.
Ja stimmt, wie setzt man eigentlich die Base URLs?
The rest line allows for a invocation override of the base URL.
seht ihr irgendwo wie hier was auf reitet wird ach da ja aber wie setze ich denn die base urls überhaupt
Was? Das setze ich in der
Config-Datei?
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, ich sage so etwas wie hier
New REST Client oder irgendwie
Build oder
in der Config?
weiß nicht gibt es hier sonst noch programmatik client creation with quarkus rest client bilder
ja ja das dass es mir lieb hier base uhr ja das machen wir das machen okay also public interface
nennen wir das ding mal api klein service service ok so hals
slash toulouse ach moment mal moment mal muss das hier verschieben effektor
move
api client service
import class
hier gibt es keine extension
sondern ein
udo item, kommt da zurück
query parameter habe ich
nicht, ich habe einen path parameter
ähm
wie war das
path parameters
so also quasi
quasi slash nach dem to do slash id das ist kein int so macht das sinn
das wollte ich mal ausprobieren
das war schon ausgleich ob das ob das passt was ich da gebaut habe geht bei
id okay das ist gut das kann so bleibt mir gut probieren wir das mal aus also
Jetzt mal
Paul und schreibt das hier rein.
Wie, was will es von mir?
Unreachable Statement.
Denk doch nicht mit für mich, Java.
Mach einfach.
Okay.
So, wie bekomme ich denn jetzt hier diesen Restclient
nochmal?
Programmatically
create Restclient.
Hier.
hier so so ok
markus west klein bilder ok gespannt
barcos rest client bilder new bilder base uri create hier base uri ist das hier
slash bild
background updater class
http client gleich field
auf uns ist jetzt jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob das klappt was hier gestrickt habe also
probieren dass man aus http client http client
Was?
Hä?
Mensch, ich bin verwirrt.
Ach, Quatsch!
API-Client-Service
muss da hin.
Jetzt macht es auch Sinn.
Komm, machen wir es richtig.
API-Client-Service muss da hin.
Okay.
HTTP-Client.
Und jetzt
get by ID 1.
Gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Okay.
War to do.
lockt du du du du keine ahnung title
eröffnet rum ja war
was ist hier los was ist hier schon wieder kaputt
Error.
Response could not be mapped to type.
Consider adding one of the...
Quarkus Resclient Jackson brauche ich doch, dass das funktioniert.
Ah, toll.
Resclient Jackson.
Abgekackt.
Schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Ja, Message hier.
Das ist die Message von dem To-Do des Funds.
Ja, das haben sie schön gemacht.
Das muss man mal sagen.
Also, nicht schlecht.
Da kann man das hier mal wieder wegmachen.
Den anderen Kram wieder
einkommentieren.
Oh, das ist nicht verkehrt.
So.
Oh, jetzt habe ich noch eine Idee.
Das ist ja ein Interface.
Kann Java so etwas wie...
So, so...
Wie heißt... Wie soll man das nennen?
So, Default-Implementierung von Methoden auf Interfaces.
Ich habe mal sowas gelesen, weil es wäre doch nice, wenn ich sowas hier hätte.
Guck mal.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Es wäre doch nice, wenn ich sowas hätte wie To-Do-Item.
Get random To-Do.
Ne, das geht nicht. Warum?
Interface abstract methods cannot have a body.
Und was macht man da jetzt?
Make static
Make default
Ah
Aha
So, dann generieren wir mal
ein random
Das vergesse ich immer, das war irgendwas mit
thread local
thread local random
Genau
Current
Next
Int
On
1 bis 99
Und dann wollen wir quasi
Return this get by
ID
Random
Schauen wir mal
Ob des funst
Gehen wir mal
Also Log
info
http client
get random to do
bam
und
ja
ah Moment, vielleicht sollten wir noch
irgendwie Titel oder so sagen
hallo
ja
ja, von uns, guck mal hier
random Titel
das schicken wir jetzt das schicken wir jetzt per websocket an unseren client
du bist im mit send new websocket message
okay das sollte man vielleicht noch eine ahnung die fault event wenn wir das
jetzt mal so
Ups.
So, nicht uptimen, einfach nur hier. Es gibt ein To-Do-Item.
New.
Vault Event.
so
was ist hier
kriegen wir das und jetzt schicken wir uns das per web sockets
hierhin
schicken uns das zu du an den client so wenn ich das jetzt richtig gemacht habe
und wir gehen jetzt hier hin
genau jetzt kriegen wir das zu du in den client geschickt jetzt kann ich sagen in
unserer index html dies öffnet ihr jason pass data title zum beispiel ja jetzt
kriegen wir einen random to do text per websocket gepusht das ging einfacher als ich mir das
vorgestellt habe.
Könnte jetzt auch ein Cache oder
irgendwie sowas dazwischen pappen, aber
wollen wir es mal nicht übertreiben.
Was ist das mit Springboot? Nein, das ist
Quarkus.
Quarkus
ist das.
Springboot haben wir schon gemacht.
in vor weiß nicht zwei wochen oder so
Da war es aber was sehr ähnliches gebaut
Ich kann jetzt gar nicht sagen was wir besser gefällt also man könnte vielleicht sagen spring wird ist vielleicht noch ein tick minimal
Kompletter mit allem was dabei ist ja
macht kaum unterschied
und es ist beides super easy und und
geht gut von der Hand, ja.
Das hier sollten wir übrigens umbenennen.
Ich creating resource
index resource
heißt es.
Also ich finde das beides nicht schlecht.
Und das obwohl ich ja kein großer
Java-Fan bin.
Finde ich nicht schlecht.
Gefällt mir, also
ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen wenn es von der technologie her passt da auf
basis das sind irgendwas zu bauen ja manchmal gut vorstellen macht spaß
beides ist beides ziemlich komplett
Das ist okay.
Was ich mich jetzt noch frage ist,
wie
ähm
wie verkontainerisieren
wir denn am besten
unsere Quarkus-Anwendung?
Guck mal, hier gibt es einen Docker-Ordner.
Docker-File?
was?
This Docker-File is used in order to build
a container that runs the Quarkus-Application
JVM-Mode. Okay, gut.
Hast du eigentlich
erklärt, was das Problem mit
Portainer
Gar kein Problem, ich mag
das nicht.
Ich sehe da keinen großartigen Mehrwert drin, außer dass ich ein GUI habe zu rumklicken, was mich eh nur nervt.
Ein Portainer ist komplett overrated, jubated.
Ne, OpenJDK 21 will ich nicht haben.
Ich will OpenJDK 25 haben.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Was meinst du, was nutze ich?
Also Pottainer sagt mir nichts.
Ach, du meinst DevPod oder sowas.
DevPod meinst du.
Das benutze ich gerade, ja.
Wir entwickeln das komplett hier in einem Container.
Ich bin auch auf dem Container connected mit meiner IDE.
Ach, das Problem.
Du meinst, warum das Connect nicht ginge?
Die Fehlermeldung war einfach kacke.
guck mal ich kann es kann ich kann er zeigen wo das problem war ich habe hier so einen
connection skript und das benutzt firefox developer edition um dieses login fenster
für die idees aufzumachen und ich hatte firefox developer edition nicht installiert und die
fehlermeldung von dem programm war einfach dumm kotner und feind gateway der hätte schreiben
müssen kunden und open browser jetzt habe ich firefox developer edition installiert und jetzt
geht sofort das war einfach nur dumm das war richtig stumpf was haben wir denn hier ubi 9
gibt es denn auch gibt es ubi ubi 10 oder was auch immer mit mit java java 25
Alter, die Redhead-Seite.
Meine Augen!
Sieht man dann hier, was die für
Container-Images haben?
Kann man hier irgendwie nachgucken, ob es das auch für OpenJDK 25 gibt?
Page.von.nice
Äh, ja
Warum machen die es eigentlich immer so kompliziert, irgendwas zu machen?
finden.
Gibt es das nicht auch?
Ubi
9 Docker Hub.
Da findet man wenigstens was.
Ja, gibt es auch. Sehr schön.
Dann gucken wir doch auf Docker Hub.
Latest
9.7 Source.
Was ist das hier?
OpenJDK.
open jdk gibt es hier gar nicht den tag ja super nice
Ubi 9
OpenJDK
Aha, hier findet man das jetzt
Containers
Aha, hier findet man nichts.
Alter, diese Seite ist so räudig von Redhead.
Ubi.
Was ist Ubi überhaupt?
Ich kenne mich im Java-Umfeld nicht gut.
Aber was ist Ubi?
Ubi.
Kann man hier nicht drinnen suchen?
Ubi 9.
Moment, ach, es gibt kein OpenJDK 25.
Universal Base Image.
Aha.
Es gibt kein Image für OpenJDK
25.
Obwohl OpenJDK 25 ist ja
vor zwei Monaten oder so schon rausgekommen.
Das ist nicht Business Enterprise genug, Leute.
Zwei Monate reichen für
Business Enterprise
Red Hat nicht, da ein Image rauszubringen.
Okay, gibt es
Ubi 10 vielleicht?
Gut, gibt kein OpenJDK 25.
Dann bauen wir ein eigenes Docker-File für unsere Anwendung.
Wir bauen ein eigenes Docker-File. Scheiß drauf.
Mir gefällt das hier eh nicht, weil die wollen, dass die Anwendung gebaut wird.
Und dann wird sie verkontainerisiert.
Das sollte im Container gebaut werden.
Die Anwendung im Container, im Multistage-Bild.
Im ersten Container soll es gebaut werden, im zweiten soll es Runtime-Containern.
Chat, was nimmt man für Java-Anwendungen?
Was gibt es denn da für gute Images?
Open JDK-Image gibt es ja nicht mehr.
Das ist ja...
Das ist ja outdated, habe ich mal gelesen.
Das official JDK-Image ist duplicated.
Guck.
Warum auch immer.
Temurin?
Stimmt.
Das habe ich immer noch nicht gecheckt.
Da gibt es zig...
Da gibt es doch so zig OpenJDK...
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das eigentlich ist.
Es gibt, da gibt es irgendwie fünf, über 50 verschiedene JDKs irgendwie.
Gibt es da irgendwie eine gescheite Übersicht, was es alles gibt?
hier genau was hier alles gibt
themo riemen
vorrette es gibt noch viel mehr
Okay, also dann wollen wir
Themorin, Themorin Docker Hub.
Gucken wir mal. Eclipse ist das.
Boah, ich habe schlechte Erinnerungen an Eclipse.
Also an die Idee, was die da bauen für Images.
Official Images for OpenJDK Binaries
Build by Eclipse Temurin
Er hat nur 100 Millionen Downloads
Easy
Was gibt es denn da?
Oh mein Gott
25 JDK Nano Server
ich weiß nicht wirklich was das bedeuten soll aber okay das haben wir dann sonst noch hier zu bieten
open cdk nano server
wir suchen wir suchen mal nach allem mit 25 trainer okay
und und und jdk oder so stimmt ich vergesse immer die suche war doch gehabt ist einfach
richtig räudig schlecht im mitnehmen wir denn da jetzt
es gibt
JDK
25 minus JDK
gibt es auch JRE?
JRE gibt es auch
weil ich brauche ja eigentlich nur den JRE
ich brauche ja kein JDK
um die Anwendung laufen zu lassen
brauche ich nur einen Java Runtime
kein Development Kit
Moment, Ubi gibt es hier auch?
Ich denke Ubi 10 gibt es nicht
Bei Red Hat gibt es kein Ubi 10
Warum gibt es hier einen Ubi?
Ah
Dieses Ökosystem macht mich durch
Macht mich verrückt
Red Hat stellt Ubi her
Red Hat sagt es gibt kein 10er Ubi
Aber es gibt aus irgendwelchen Gründen
eine Eclipse
Temurin 25 JRE
Ubi.
Alter!
Das soll aber irgendeiner
checken, Mann.
Wir versuchen, ein Docker-File
für die Anwendung zu bauen.
Grafana
Alloy. Keine Ahnung.
Okay, wir nehmen jetzt einfach
das hier. Ohne Scheiß. Ich habe jetzt keinen Bock,
da lange rum zu machen.
wir nehmen jetzt einfach ubi minimal okay okay vielleicht soll er das
vielleicht sollte man das docker file noch mal ein bisserl was machen die hier
eigentlich gerade also wenn ich das richtig verstehe wenn ich dieses docker
feil hier richtig checke die wollen dass man die anwendung einmal bildet und
danach die gebildete anwendung verpackt die halten wohl nichts davon dass man
die Anwendung in einem Docker-Container baut.
Machen wir es erst mal so.
Machen wir es erst mal so, wie
die das
schreiben. Also wir sollen
Maven-Package machen.
Also Maven Package.
Das kann ich ja hier in meinem Container machen.
Na, brechen wir das mal ab.
Sagen jetzt Maven Package.
Lädt er erstmal das halbe Internet runter.
So wie das sein.
Tests.
Er lässt wirklich Tests laufen bei meinem Programm.
Oh.
Äh.
Moment, das ist abgekackt, weil meine Tests gefailt sind.
Tests. Sekunde.
Wo sind meine Tests?
Ich sehe sie überhaupt nicht.
Wo sind die? Ach, hier.
Tests.
Delete.
Wer braucht da irgendwelche Tests?
Oh, Package.
Ja, jetzt tut man nicht so, als gäbe es noch irgendwelche Tests.
Was?
Es gibt keine Tests mehr.
Ich habe die gelöscht.
Wie?
Woher weiß der, dass es Tests gibt?
Hä?
Ach, Mavenclean.
Der hat noch das alte Zeug.
Okay.
Das Docker-File, das moven wir mal.
Okay, wir lassen das Docker-File mal da.
Das passt schon.
Also.
Maven-Package habe ich ausgeführt.
Okay, dann tauschen wir jetzt mal das Image aus.
Eclipse, Timurin 25.
minimal nvm language so das heißt der
moment dass die docker falls da liegen das bringt doch überhaupt nichts das
funks doch gar nicht
irgendwie ist das ziemlich pp
probier's mal aus also wisst ihr was scheiß drauf wir
ich lösche das hier wobei das hier kann man ja so lassen das hier lassen wir so
ich kopiere mir das einfach mal schnell cbs source docker locker locker fall
locker fall jvm das kopieren wir uns jetzt einfach mal hier hin in das
hauptverzeichnis und jetzt editieren wir hier drin immer und so ganz kommt da wieder weg
noch schon ein bisschen besser durch so dann wollen wir das image haben es ran
als multistage bild noch machen ein wein mit language englisch das können wir so lassen das
ist okay ja gut wir haben es jetzt ja gebaut wir können es darüber kopieren
expose 80 80 user 185 warum auch immer scheiß drauf user 85
heckl alter es läuft völlig als root
bisschen was muss man für die hacker mänze übrig lassen
mir fällt übrigens gerade auf das total umständlich was die hier machen warum
warum weil ich scheiße wir kopieren einfach nur barcos app slash app so vorher sagen wir noch
work deal slash app
kopieren das dahin
wir brauchen hier hinten auch ein slash sonst mag er das nicht
Das brauchen wir alles nicht
Jetzt nur die Frage
Wie man das Java
Zeug startet
Wie würde ich das denn
Okay, das war eine blöde Frage
Wie würde ich das denn von Hand überhaupt starten
Wir haben hier ein Target
Quarkus App
Quarkus Run Jar
Also quasi
Java minus Jar
Quarkus Run Jar
Ach easy
Oh, was hat er denn jetzt?
Äh, was so?
hatte was hat der irgendwelche schmerzen gehabt an die shutdown event war das
und so da gehen wir uns das docker feil dick ist dicker feil
ja ja ja ja ja ich hab das doch noch auf so und dann machen wir jetzt
entry point ich schreibe aus versehen öfter sticker file java und dann app
warum ist denn die maus unterstützung für wim an das ist ja ganz abartig quarkus app
einfach nur einfach nur quarkus ranja so ohne scheiß das müsste alles sein was man braucht
keine ahnung man kann es auch kompliziert machen mit dem image oder so kommt man überhaupt
funktioniert locker bild minus t1 besser tech ach so ja klar das muss ich auf einem haus jetzt
Ich frag mich wie fett das Image am Ende ist.
Fertig. Ja, dann.
Docker run.
Wie habe ich jetzt genannt?
Ah, 0w1.
Tatsächlich.
Docker run.
Ja. Läuft.
Max, mal eine andere Frage.
Was würde dich derzeit bewegen, den Arbeitgeber zu wechseln?
Du meinst,
Was mir jemand anderes bieten müsste oder was mein aktueller Arbeitgeber verkacken müsste, dass ich wechseln will.
Ich habe keine Wechselambitionen gerade.
Ansonsten im Zweifelsfall, ich bin bestechlich.
Also wenn mir jetzt einer einfach doppelt so viel Geld gibt, dann würde ich mir das natürlich überlegen.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass ich einen Turnschuh-Admin-Job will.
Ich habe gesagt, ich würde für jemanden ins Rechenzentrum gehen und da Zeug austauschen.
Es ist nicht, dass ich das als hauptberuflichen Job machen will.
Das würde ich sogar umsonst machen.
Kostenfrei, genau.
Also, Chat, jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Guckt euch mal dieses fette
Docker-File hier an mit Zeug.
Ja, Gedöns.
Na gut, so fett ist das gar nicht.
Versus Mainz.
Mainz ist doch deutlich schöner, oder?
Darf den Router...
Ich musste heute schon meinen Vodafone-Router neu starten.
Meins ist inklusive Sicherheitslücken.
Ja, noch besser, oder?
Aber einen User anlegen und CH-Ownen könnte ich auch.
Wollen wir das mal ausprobieren?
Wenn ich dem jetzt sage,
wir machen das gleiche wir machen das gleiche gleiche wie hier jetzt sehen das beim kopieren
auf 100 anscheinend erscheint ja in diesem ubi image den user zu sein 185
bild
Zack
Und schon läuft es nicht mehr als root
Easy
Fertig
Jetzt haben wir noch nicht mal mehr
Großartige Sicherheitsdinger drin
Trotzdem ist mein Image schöner
Mein Dockerfile schöner
Und mein Image besser
Ich würde sagen
Chat
Das
Komplettiert jetzt
oder das
der Quarkus-Ark
ist vorbei.
Wir haben eine ordentliche Anwendung zusammen
gezimmert, mit
allem möglichen Kram drin.
Das funktioniert.
Wir haben ein Docker-Image gebaut, in dem es läuft.
Damit haben wir erstmal
genug Quarkus für nächste
Zeit.
Ach Moment, nee, haben wir nicht.
Nicht genug Quarkus, genug Java
wollte ich sagen für nächste Zeit.
Quarkus haben wir nicht genug
da machen wir nämlich noch
ein Kotlin Stream, wo wir das Ding
nachbauen in Kotlin
und da bin ich mal gespannt, was mir besser
gefällt
ob Java 25
oder Kotlin
da
ja, mal gucken
ich hab schon irgendwann mal ein bisschen Kotlin
gemacht, sogar auch on stream
aber ich weiß gar nichts mehr
das müssen wir auch machen ja ich weiß nicht wann wir das machen
aber ich gehe jetzt was einkaufen was er das mit kotlinge das kann schon sein ich glaube da gibt
es größere überschneidungen auch zwischen anderen sprachen und features von anderen sprachen die mir
gefallen, die es so auch in Kotlin gibt.
Gucken wir dann.
Okay, Leute. Schön, dass ihr dabei
wart. Wenn es euch gefallen hat, einmal Follow drücken.
Würde mich freuen. Und wir sehen uns
im nächsten Stream. Bis dann.
See you.